failed Maga candidate Michelle Fiore has  been appointed a judge in the state of  Nevada despite having absolutely no  background in the law many people don't  know that in many states anybody can be  appointed judge and that is indeed what  is happening with Michelle Fiore now you  have to remember you and I might look at  this and say this is embarrassing this  is the this is just horrible it doesn't  make any sense but you have to remember  that the modern Maga right sees  education as left-wing indoctrination  they see expertise as left-wing  propaganda and they take pride in being  against education Not educated formally  anti-intellectual pseudo-intellectual  they see that as a feature not a bug in  what you end up with is people like  Michelle Fiore appointed despite having  no legal expertise whatsoever to be a  judge